le cri brûlé on veut vous tuer
malheureusement ne peux pas répondre à
cette question parce que justement on ne
peut pas revenir en arrière
moi je me reconnais pas là-dedans moi
c'est la violence gratuite nous notre
métier à nous ce n'est pas de servir de
punching ball populaire salue c'est hugo
il ya quelques jours on a réuni
policiers et citoyens dont certains
citoyens très critique vis-à-vis de la
police c'est le retour du format
hexagone sur cette nouvelle chaîne
youtube
hugo décrypte vous êtes déjà plus de
cent mille en quelques jours merci
beaucoup pour votre soutien il va être
pour chacun d'entre vous de choisir
pour commencer trois mots qui
définissent le mieux la police selon
j'ai choisi violence insécurité et
racisme donc pour moi ces protections
vocation les urgences et gémit pouvoir
autorités et contrôle du coup j'ai mis
sécurité protection et paix ordre peur
des sécurités ordre sécurité et paix je
pense que d'un côté il ya les les
valeurs de l'institution
ouais c'est ça et pour nous c'est plus
que ce qu'on ressent aussi leur sens
ticona personnellement j'ai déjà été
victime du coup de d'intimidation de la
part de la police
je pestais siagi 27 ans j'habite en
région parisienne aujourd'hui j'aimerais
parler du fait qu'en présence de
policiers je ne le sens pas en sécurité
en tant que personnes noires j'étais en
fait un jour un oeil beurre j'avais un
driver qui a été du coup blanc c'est
important de le préciser du coup vous
comprendrez par la suite pourquoi est en
fait sur le chemin c'est contrôlé par la
police
c'était pendant confinement j'avais une
attestation trois de ses policiers
viennent vers ma fenêtre ou là je sens
qu'on commence à à m'intimider on me
demande mes papiers etc
donc je les passe et puis là on me
demande de sortir de la voiture je ne
sais pas pourquoi
sachant que j'avais donné mon
arrestation et ma pièce d'identité
je sors de la voiture on me met contre
la voiture je me fais encerclé du coup
par les policiers sur le coup j'étais
choquée et
sincèrement j'avais peur je remonte dans
la voiture et là j'entends du coup
devant le policier qui parle du coup
avec mon driver et qui lui dit est-ce
que vous avez une attestation - et là le
driver du sort une attestation périmés
qui n'était même pas valable et là le
policier lui jacques momha c'est bon
vous pouvez partir on part du coup la
malaise le driver lui-même le dit mais
écoutez j'avoue j'ai un peu mal à l'aise
de ce qui vient de se passer parce que
je vois la façon dont on vous a contrôlé
et je sais très bien qu'on ne m'a pas
contrôlée de cette façon parce que je
suis blanc c'est problématique qu'en
tant que personnes noires et racisées
aujourd'hui en france on ne puisse pas
se sentir en sécurité et qu'on ait peur
faut savoir que le contrôle est
réglementée par le code de procédure
pénale
d'accord je m'appelle gates ans j'ai 25
ans je suis bien de la paix dans un
service d'investigation
donc c'est quand même vachement stricte
et réglementaires ne fait pas tout et
n'importe quoi c'est peut-être des
choses qui se sont passées par exemple
un enfant qui a été enlevée nous faut
quand même qu'on lève le doute
à chaque fois à 100% vous vous le
ressentez comme ça mais nous on fait on
fait notre métier de contrôle alors je
peux comprendre et sage l'autre
complètement après pour moi il ya des
manières de contrôler les personnes et
les contrôles musclés justement ça s'est
passé c'est clairement pas normal pour
moi je m'appelle jérémy j'ai 34 ans je
suis gardien de la paix ont police
secours
on se contrôle quelqu'un
je fais pas attention à ces implants
c'est un arabe si c'est un noir ou quoi
quand il ya des dérives qui sont faites
par des policiers on a plus tendance à
dire ouais c'est pas la police qui est
comme ça c'est ce policier là qu'il a
eue ce mois c'est ce qui me dérange
c'est ce qui me dérange quasiment le
plus
je m'appelle maxime j'ai 30 ans et je
suis photojournaliste indépendant
spécialisé dans le maintien de l'ordre
et dans les violences policières
c'est l'humain qui va juger et pas la
hiérarchie
si les désordres qui ont posé des
problèmes tout ça il manque cette prise
de conscience se se poser des questions
sur est ce qu'on fait tout bien
il manque ça je trouve
envoyer six images qu est ce que vous
pensez qu est ce que ça vous fait réagir
la police a beaucoup changé les plus
jeunes de la société porte un regard qui
est différent et bonnet ne se
déplaceront pas pour acclamer la police
nationale si je m'appelle alexandra j'ai
25 ans et j'ai vu des choses en
manifestation qui me font me poser des
questions sur le système politique
actuel
moi c'est plus je pense une différence
de contexte où là on était dans de
l'antiterrorisme donc c'était bon et
avait valu d'être soudés et soudée il
s'agit et sauver des gens vous nous
protège et aux quatre coins de la france
c'était pas du tout le même le même
rapport et quand la police fait des
choses bien il faut le dire quand la
police vivent des choses tragiques il
faut le dire mais il faut aussi dire
quand ça va pas qui s'est passé là en
fait c'est qu'il ya eu un acte qui s'est
passé du qu'on nous applaudit parce
qu'on a fait stopper l'acte et cd joué
presque tous les jours des as oui oui le
fait de dire qu'il ya un réel problème
de fond est un réel dysfonctionnement au
sein de la police n'annule pas les
choses positives que la police peut
faire et ça le souligner souligné du
coup le côté négatif
nanou la fin ne relève en rien ce que
vous faites de positif pour savoir quand
même on a énormément de personnes dans
la population française qui sont
toujours comme ça à ça nous a beaucoup
qui aiment leur police pense
qu'aujourd'hui en france
la population est beaucoup dans
l'émotion c'est à dire que quand il
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé pendant
les attentats et ce qui en a suivi avec
l'acclamation des forces de l'ordre etc
ça a été très vite oubliée dès que j'ai
eu un petit
un problème au niveau police qui a été
pointée du doigt oui mais ça les gens
ils essayeront de vous dire aussi que je
dis qu'on est dans l'émotion oui oui la
police n'a pas un comportement normal on
a pu voir avec michel c'est clair michel
à damas il y en a beaucoup
des exemples comme ça je vous laisse en
discuter est ce dangereux d'être en
manifestation aujourd'hui
oui bah oui ça dépend dans quelle
manifestation mais ça dépend des wii et
stations mais oui comme c'est très vrai
mais je pense que du coup c'est dans les
deux camps quand on trouve aussi que
c'est dangereux les uns pour l'héroïne
oui je m'appelle salim j'ai 26 ans et
j'ai été sous-officiers de la
gendarmerie pendant sept ans chez lui
masquer pour pouvoir parler librement
sans avoir d'attaché de communication de
l'institution un escale ans et à peu
près 120 militaires de la gendarmerie
mobile qui peuvent faire face à presque
des fois trois quatre cinq six mille
personnes
oui quand même la cargaison elle ses
textes
ça éviterait même en eau tout fait moi
juste avec mon uniforme dans ces rafales
et au coup de pavés parce qu'on est que
100 personnes
une fois que les sons sont couchés
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais vous auriez
pas les armures vous prendrez pas moins
beaucoup moins revenir je suis pas sûr
en fait faut savoir que l'action de la
police va se mettre par rapport à le
comportement de la foule
c'est effectivement devant il ya des
mecs qui sont en train de savate et les
les les gendarmes mobiles ou les crs au
bout d'un monde va y avoir une réponse
des forces de l'ordre oui 18 décembre
2018 sur les champs-elysées le 8
décembre pourrait pas décrire ces il y
avait des bals de flash ball qui
partaient dans tous les sens nous sont
passés à côté de la tête on sentait le
filet d'air puis moi j'ai été blessé
plusieurs fois alors que juif identifier
je me suis fait insulter je me suis fait
menacer donc moi je vais évoquer une
autre date c'est le 1er décembre 2018
sauf que moi c'était pas à paris où
j'étais c'était dans une petite commune
de haute loire moins que puy en velay
tout le monde est rentré dans la
préfecture ça a déversé des pneus dans
la préfecture et ça a voulu mettre le
feu et il ya quand même la volonté des
personnes quand même qu'ils sont là l e
elle le crie brûlé on va vous tuer oui
mais ce kilo ce qui l'aurait fait il ya
un policier qui aurait pu se faire
massacrer par les manifestants vraiment
donc il ya pas cette volonté non plus
des manifestants de tuer c'est plus
faire reculer faire peur à l'émettre de
trois coups s'il faut mais ça ira jamais
plus loin moi je parlais plus haut sont
su mais individuellement le mec qui est
devant et que son bouclier sans but
c'est pas de recevoir les premiers coups
ou quoi que ce soit elle rentrait chez
lui avec des bleus ont brassé ses
enfants avec une dent en moins
je ne me fais pas de servir de punching
ball populaire à coups de rétablissement
de l'ordre
alors malheureusement pour vous le but
c'est de faire tampon à la colère est
fait pour moi le but c'est pas de me
dire on va aujourd'hui je mets mon
plastron de protection et mon bouclier
et me dire moi j'espère que je pourrai
avoir trop de le sort que je pense que
aujourd'hui en 2021 ce serait bien trop
compliqué et peut-être même stérile
d'essayer de revenir à qui de la police
ou les manifestants comme l'oeuf ou la
poule c prévenait en premier utile voilà
mais oui mais le problème c'est ça c'est
que quand tu dis peut-être que si vous
n'étiez pas aussi armé vous ne prendrez
pas des pavés moi je pense aussi que
c'est possible
malheureusement on ne peut pas répondre
à cette question parce que justement on
peut pas revenir en arrière et
évidemment il faut pas qu'il prenne le
risque de non plus tous ces reports les
violences policières existe-t-elle et
levez la main ceux qui considèrent que
les violences policières existe
aujourd'hui un poste à l'est pour ce
qu'on appelle view serait déjà ça me
fait plaisir que vous ayez lever la main
non vraiment ouais des collègues qui en
arrivent à frapper un individu qui est
menotté ça par exemple pour moi ça
rentre dans ce que vous appelez les
violences les violences policières
c'est pas systématique mais ça existe et
pas de mon point de vue c'est une
majorité dans la police qui agissent
comme ça et moi je pense que justement
c'est une grande minorité s'il s'agit
d'une minorité
vous en tant que majorité est ce que
vous prenez position m'a dit qu'il avait
été confronté tous les racismes
violences aggravées fanta soir par
contre faut savoir que oui on a la
possible
de faire remonter l'information nous on
nous apprend à l'école on nous dit si on
est témoin de ce genre de choses on doit
aviser d'ailleurs j'aime avoir des
rapports écrits
est-ce que vous avez un quelconque
pouvoir pour dire là je pense que
l'ordre qu'on me donne
il est justement pas légitime et moi en
tant qu'être humain derrière mon
uniforme je n'ai pas envie de le faire
si on te donne un ordre officiel qui est
dans les textes de loi
tu dois six états hiérarchie tu exécutes
il ya quand même des textes encore une
fois de plus nous permettent d'utiliser
la force
moi je me suis fait matraquer au crâne
avec un brassard 13 ans quand il ya un
crime ou un délit qui a été commis qu'on
intervient sur les lieux et qu'on doit
appréhender une personne si la personne
ne se laisse pas faire voeu se
soustraire à son contrôle ou autre on
est autorisée à faire usage de la
violence si elle veut l'entendre nous on
violence y est les violentes envers
d'autres personnes on peut faire usage
de la violence
après c'est toujours pareil il faut que
ça soit strictement proportionnée par
rapport à l'acte de la personne qu'on a
en face de nombreux exemples démontrent
que très souvent les gens se font
agresser par la police de façon
complètement gratuite justifier sa part
des textes de loi que vous avez ou des
ddd des règlements que vous avez au
centre votre institution je trouve
sincèrement extrêmement dérangeant et
quand je dis texte c'est parce que je
sais pas le terme
il ya un texte donc j'allais fracassé
quelqu'un serristes point ça n'a aucun
policier qui va se lever le matin en
disant tiens aujourd'hui dans fracassant
le texte veut dire qu'en fait on peut
appliquer la stricte force nécessaire
pour faire cesser une infraction d'année
merdy la défense
personnellement je pense que c'est un
débat sans fin
c'est bien d'avoir eu la possibilité de
discuter du coup avec vous d'échangés
aussi avec vous de vous entendre vous
êtes ce que vous soyez aussi en position
si de nous écouter de nous entendre
je resterai quand même sur mais sur mes
positions je ne pense pas que les choses
vont changer forcément du jour au
lendemain mais je trouve ça en effet
mais je trouve ça intéressant et
important d'avoir ce genre de discussion
pour conscientiser le problème est
comment s'est du coup à faire évoluer
les consciences et à faire changer les
choses
je pense que le débat qu'on a là à notre
niveau pour que ça fasse avancer les
choses
recueillez les mêmes types de débats
plus toutes les toutes les choses
négatives que vous avez vécu et que vous
avez fait ressortir la pendant le débat
en fait moi quand moi je me reconnais
pas là-dedans en fait est de me dire que
quand j'interviens auprès d'une personne
elle peut se dire ça en me voyant en moi
mais s'assure que moi je suis pas sa
fabrication à façon on s'était croisé
dans la rue j'en ai fait une peur de
nous oui non mais c'est sûr échange un
trottoir quasiment merci beaucoup pour
cet échange c'est super intéressant à
voir comme ça aux différents points de
vue on se retrouve donc tout de suite en
gros vous allez passer au débrief pour
pouvoir nous dire justement ce que vous
retenez de ce débat mais c'était marc a
vraiment un problème de son les
comportements individuels au sein de ces
institutions ne reflète pas l'image
globale des forces de l'ordre derrière
l'uniforme il ya quand même un humain
également sortir du anti et pro flics
mais je ne sais pas si les choses
changeront prochainement corps des
policiers également peuvent subir le
système est de voir que c'est beaucoup
plus complexe et humain que ça c'est
compliqué de se révolter en interne et
de dénoncer ce qui va pas du fait que
justement ils n'ont pas ces
informations-là sur la manière de
travailler de la police